of our relationship but uh
i'm not sure exactly
not sure exactly okay we'll give it a
second
all right so uh in the interim as we
work out our technical difficulties um
this is what we're talking about this
evening
this is my cool shirt that i had made
and it says
end h3c now h3c
it stands for human human
cause climates crisis which is an h and
three c's
let's call it what it is so that there
is no
equivocation it is a crisis
that is caused by human
activity um so that's kind of what we're
here for this evening
we have uh some great scientists
that you'll be hearing from um dr
peter mahofey uh from cave
king center for visualization science
visualization of science which is a
wonderful resource
that i have used to find out about
uh climate issues it's a great way if
you have students to take them in
and show them um certain things about
the atmosphere
and it's i'll let peter tell you about
it okay uh
and then we also have uh catherine
hayehoe
who is probably one of the most
in my estimation prolific science
uh climate communicators on the planet
she of course is a climate scientist
uh you may have seen her ted talk but
she is one of the people that makes it
so
very plain and i call her a crystalline
voice
with respect to uh the climate crisis
neil yeah hey hey there is neil
can you hear me i can hear you oh thank
you for like bringing everybody in while
i'm messing with my
my technicalities no worries no worries
i love the vest look at you we must be
doing something stuff
you dressed up for the teachers the
teachers are special
the teachers are special you're not
gonna wear my sunday best
we have been together since march on
zoom i haven't seen you
the last time i saw you was in march and
this is the first time i have seen
you let me turn it back on you is that
the best you can do is wear a t-shirt
for this event
it's a very important t-shirt yes it is
so i you did some introducing while i
came in so
so this is our first live on on virtual
right so did you cover that i did not
yeah so people just so they know we we
do this
often during the year several times a
year on in theaters on a stage where we
have guests and comedians
and so it's a it's it's a very important
annual thing we do
multiple times a year but seasonally
really and but now of course
the covidiverse has forced us into
virtual mode and chuck and i have been
virtualizing for
many months now so i think we've got a
rhythm going yeah but chuck
okay you're wearing a t-shirt now you
gotta explain the t-shirt because it's
in code
have you explained it yet yeah well no
it says nh3c now and that's human cause
climate crisis and h and three c's i
know for somebody like you who's a
who's a scientist it's probably some uh
molecular composition as well
but for us for us stupid people
it's human human cause climate crisis
agent three c's and the reason is is
trying to put a name to it that means
something
and so um i've been active in the
climate space now for a couple years
trying to yes i'm very impressed by that
chuck i mean yeah i
only learned about this sort of after
the fact
so i'm very proud of you that you were
doing this like and you didn't tell me
you just
i went out there and did it yeah you
know it's you know i just wanted to get
involved and do my part by
you know however i have to say it's my
association with star talk you know
we would often have on scientists and a
lot of people
i'm going to reveal so when we have
scientists on i often will read their
their their work and the reason is i
don't
want to be the idiot in the room
you're a trained scientist and you're
talking to trained scientists
you guys have a shorthand you know how
to talk to one another and i don't want
to be the guy sitting there going
oh uh this might be funny so i wonder
so chuck chuck chuck chuck um there's an
old saying
right right and i first heard this from
michael dell actually founder of dell
computers
um if you're the smartest person in the
room
change rooms there you go i love that
okay i'm keeping that yeah well that's
that's that's the deal
so um yeah so i started reading up a lot
of uh
a lot of research on this and it's
horrifying it was horrifying it
horrified me and i had to do something
so i started a campaign called it's real
and uh it's a
communication campaign uh to get young
people to
become actionist take action everybody
should do something
that's that's my whole goal just do your
part it's an all hands on debt
issue and everybody can do
something if we all do something that
means we're all thinking about it if
we're all thinking about it
that means we're all looking for a
solution
and when you talk about you know there's
citizen science
but uh citizen solution yeah
citizen solutions a whole other holding
of another all another another so that's
when you also that this is climate week
in new york city
i did not and i i should have so this is
climate week that's why we're doing it
here and now
live on facebook and youtube
and of course this is a collaboration
with pocket lab they've become our
recent very good friends in this space
and
so i think it's time to bring in our
first guest
oh by the way at the end of this program
there's going to be a q a so stick
around
that's usually the most vibrant part of
the start talk lives
as anyone who has seen us in theaters
knows
so definitely stick around and we'll be
soliciting your questions in the live
feeds
from both facebook and youtube and
i will be pumping them in to our
exchange so let's do this
um okay so first a climate scientist
catherine
hey ho she's been on star talk before
because this is this is not a topic we
haven't
addressed and she's the director of the
texas tech
university climate center professor of
political science
and a un champion of the earth
have to find out what that precisely
means and you said you've heard her ted
talk is that right
absolutely yeah let's bring her up yeah
go ahead
yes hi there she goes catherine hello
hey
okay you get you get you get the you get
the award for least interesting backdrop
it's very deliberate
all right so could you could you put it
on catherine
catherine actually looks like she's
calling in from a passport photo
well i am canadian
so tell just put us all on the same page
when scientists speak of climate change
just just put us on the same page there
what what what do we mean when we say
climate change
we mean the change in the long-term
average conditions of the planet
so our brain are wired to remember
whether a hot day
a snowy day a crazy storm that's like a
single tree climate is like the forest
it's the average of weather over at
least 20 to 30 years
and that's what's changing today and
that's why we can still have hot weather
and cold weather
even while the entire planet is warming
very cool um i'm hoping neil is
is neil playing like he's stuck nope
he's actually stuck
there he is he's back yes
okay i dropped out there for a sec so
hold on
are we all still there yeah we're here
we see okay sorry
and we're seeing you yeah so what what
when did you
when did when did global warming change
to climate change
when did that happen and why we find
chess i've always called it climate
change global warming is more of a
popular term
global warming is a symptom of climate
change
it's like you're running a fever but the
disease you have is not the fever the
fever is just the symptom
so the disease is climate change and
we're seeing an increase in the average
temperature of the
planet but we're also seeing a lot of
other things things are changing in the
places where we live
we see wildfires are burning greater and
greater area
we see hurricanes are getting bigger and
stronger
we see that heavy rain events are
getting more frequent and heat waves are
getting more intense
and so personally if i'm going to call
it something i usually call it global
weirding very nice
okay something like a new dance or
something yeah we should have been weird
should have gone with that from the
beginning would have would have
definitely got a lot more people
involved
and so so is is there some um
climate change people always want to
blame
today's weather on a climate change so
how how do you
how do you advise people to think about
weather versus climate
in terms of what you're going to blame
the the
the anthropogenic factors on
so weather is kind of like your mood and
climate is like your personality you can
be in a good mood or a bad mood
but long term you're a certain type of
person at the same time though we know
that climate change is affecting our
weather and here's how
so imagine you have a pair of dice and
you always have a chance of rolling a
double six that's an extreme weather
event
but decade by decade as the planet warms
it's as if it's sneaking in and taking
another one of those sixes
oh sorry another number and turning it
into a six and then another one and
turning into a seven
and so pretty soon you're rolling all
kinds of double sixes and even some
sevens like you never used to before and
you're like what is going on
that's climate change and that is why
but on your stereo system can you turn
it up to 11
though that's really what people
so in the case of climate change yes yes
okay
okay because it is odd when people say
we haven't had floods this high
since 1936 well you had floods that high
in 1936 when no one was talking about
climate change so if the comparison to
the highs today
are always indexed to something long ago
what you're really saying is it's not
that it's high specifically but that
we're having a lot of them
and like you said someone is is is load
preloading the dice
so that the six the double sixes is no
longer rare it's becoming common
yeah another way to think about it is
like a baseball player they hit the
occasional home run and then they went
on steroids and they started to hit a
lot more homework
so it wasn't that a home run was
unprecedented it's just that their
statistics changed and that's what's
happening with climate change
and tell me about the paris accord the
paris agreement
you know we get snippets of it he you
know in in this in the united states
it's are we part of it are we not
we change leadership and then someone
undoes it so
where was it where where has it been
where was it and where is it now
and what's our relationship to it yes so
i was there
i was in paris when this all happened
and what happened was almost
every country in the entire world got
together and agreed to limit
global temperature change to at least
two degrees celsius
and if possible one and a half and just
as a benchmark we're already at one
degree today
so that's where we were and then pretty
much every country in the world signed
on and then president trump announced
that he would be withdrawing the u.s
from the agreement
but he can't officially do it until just
before the election in november
so it hasn't actually happened yet and
if he does withdraw the us they can go
back in after just a couple more weeks
but here's the thing it isn't just about
federal government solving this problem
it is about organizations like cities
and states
corporations universities tribal nations
um uh religious denominations and so
they've all gotten together in the u.s
and organizations that represent almost
half of u.s emissions have agreed that
they're still in on the paris agreement
so it's not a zero or one we're already
half of us are committed to be there we
just need the other half to come along
and for that we need the federal
government
but it isn't just the us if you look
globally at all the commitments all the
countries have made
that only adds up to three degrees we
haven't got enough yet to get down to
two it's kind of like a potluck dinner
and everybody's supposed to bring enough
to feed everybody well there
isn't enough food on the table yet so
far we're only going to hold global
temperature to three degrees not two
degrees so we don't just need the u.s we
need more from almost everyone else
but catherine in any given day
especially in dry climates
the temperature swings 20 30 40 degrees
from mid-afternoon
to just before sunrise and so why
what can you tell people for them to be
concerned about a mere
two degree rise in the average i hear
exactly what you're saying and i've
actually thought about how to explain
this and here's what i would say
the temperature of the planet is as
stable as that of the human body
so if you add up all of the temperature
around the whole world it can be really
cold one place
it could be really warm the other but at
the scale of the planet it's as stable
as the human body and our human body
temperature you know 98 degrees that's
pretty warm
but if our body temperature goes up one
degree fahrenheit or if it goes up
almost
two degrees fahrenheit which is one
degree celsius somebody stuck a
thermometer in you and you're laying up
in bed
exactly and that's why this matters
planet is running a fever
so what we need is a giant thermometer
that we can stick in australia
and uh basically constantly monitor the
planet
why australia because that's the bottom
chuck where are you going with this
truck
i'm scarred from my childhood didn't
they didn't have those things you just
pointed at your forehead when i was a
kid
you could at least have said the south
pole okay i mean there's a lot of ways
you could have gotten around that
rather than invoking an entire continent
and nation
yes and actually let me tell you
something really cool the very first
person to collect weather station data
because we do use weather stations all
around the world
the very first person to collect all
that data and show that the planet was
warming
was a british engineer called guy
calendar in 1938.
wow and he sounds like a game show host
that's very cool i'm a guy calendar
all right so so why all right so tell me
precisely what is warming the planet
okay let me be more precise than that we
know greenhouse gases trap
solar energy and it's remains in the
atmosphere and the temperature goes up
what are the sources of this excess
greenhouse excess carbon dioxide
greenhouse gases
yes so first of all as you know neil
our planet already has a natural blanket
of heat trapping gases
that keeps our planet the perfect
temperature for life we'd be a frozen
ball of ice if we didn't have this
natural blanket
so what's the problem the problem by the
way in fact in my field we call it
snowball earth
yes times when times when you know the
the
the the right amount of greenhouse was
not happening no
it wasn't so we're kind of like
goldilocks we don't want
too much of it because then we'd be like
venus we don't want too little of it
because that would be the snowball earth
so the sun's energy actually goes mostly
through this blanket sort of like a
window the earth heats up the earth
gives off infrared or heat energy
and the blanket traps the heat energy
just like a blanket traps our body heat
at night
same way so what's the problem the
problem is we are wrapping an
extra blanket around the planet that it
doesn't need it's like somebody is
sneaking into your room at night
which is sort of creepy when you think
about it and putting an extra blanket on
you and you wake up sweating
someone who loves you who puts on an
extra blanket my grandma would always
grandma coming in with a crocheted with
the crochet blanket yes
yes we had central heating in canada but
she was convinced it didn't work so she
always came in every night with a
blanket when i was at her house
so where is this blanket coming from uh
about
three three quarters of it 75 percent is
coming from digging up
and burning fossil fuels 75
25 of it is coming from land use change
and agriculture
specifically deforestation and
animal agriculture because so
deforestation because plants
take in carbon dioxide and they build
themselves off and give off oxygen you
take away plants
you're removing a sink for or an
absorbing
factor in the carbon dioxide that's
correct yes but
also when you burn them it releases the
carbon in the trees into the atmosphere
too so it's a double whammy
okay but but if okay but if you if you
have a tree that had carbon dioxide that
it took out of the air and then you burn
the tree it puts it back in
isn't that neutral it is but if you're
deforesting area and you're not putting
the trees back again
so now the tree is no longer taking the
scrubbing the atmosphere
of carbon dioxide yes so that's why i'm
growing up in canada if you want to earn
a lot of money in the summer to pay for
university you would go tree planting
because some countries like bhutan and
like canada they tree plant like
fiends and what they're doing is they're
cutting down the trees but then they're
replacing them so the net impact on
carbon
is neutral but what's happening is due
to all the wildfires and due to all of
the pests and beetles that are eating
the trees
even in canada the forests have been in
that source of carbon the last decade or
more
rather than in that sink well wait you
don't you can't just throw in beetles
out of nowhere
beetles and insects what how does
climate change affect
our insect population oh you meant
insects i thought you were talking about
the beetles
i was these beetles
i do not want to speak to whether the
beetles perform incest or not but they
are inserted
and what is happening is there are
beetles that eat trees
and cold winters kill them off so if
they get killed off in the cold winter
you only have one generation of beetles
every year
but if you have a really warm winter it
doesn't kill them off so you have
baby parents grandparents and
great-grandparent beetles
eating the trees and they eat millions
of acres of trees
and so then when a wildfire starts all
the trees are dried up and they can burn
up
oh because they eat them they kill them
and then again and they become dry
and britain and and they they actually
become an accelerant at that point
yeah yeah a kindle kindle before the
original meaning of the word
kindle i think yeah
yeah and and tinder right but you know
they all had previous meanings before
the internet
but uh so it sounds like all of the
problems that
that we're discussing here are self
exacerbating they act the one problem
becomes a domino
to exacerbate another problem which
becomes this vicious circle
so it's a spiral downwards it's you know
you're
that that's that's very scary
so so you're talking about a a sort of a
a self-feeding
loop yeah yeah yeah so with amplifying
feedback
we don't want to call it a positive
feedback because that sounds good right
feedback it's like you did a great job
self-amplifying or even a vicious cycle
and the worst vicious cycles are in the
arctic
yeah all right so so what do you what do
you plan to do about this
no you we yes you catherine
what the hell is your problem catherine
well
you are the u.n hero of the planet you
are the one
yeah that's what i was doing last year
you're what does that even mean
what does it mean to be a u.n hero what
does that mean well i showed up and i
was expecting the case
you showed up that's all it took no i
was expecting the cape and the
superpowers
and i did not get them and i'm severely
disappointed because i thought the whole
deal was you got those and then you
saved the planet right
gotcha gotcha gotcha i mean captain
marvel yeah yeah you don't have
superpowers you're because you're
basically the canadian captain marvel
i would like to be and in fact actually
i have a fantastic colleague who's based
in new york
her name is also catherine but she goes
by kate and her last name is even marvel
so i would be totally oh you're not kate
marvel yeah
i would be happy if she got the cake too
we've had her several times on
star talk but let's ask so we want to do
something about it because we don't want
to warm the earth outside of our
understandings of
our civilization or capacity of
civilization to
accommodate it so do we all become vegan
do we
stop having kids do we what are some
easy things
fast things because we're all lazy you
know so
what's the simplest easy thing to do
well
that is the number one question i
started to get when i started to talk to
people about climate change i was like
well i'm a scientist i don't fix this
problem i tell you how bad it is
but that's not satisfying because you
can't have somebody tell you there's a
problem and not tell you how to fix it
so i've thought about this for a really
long time because we could each do
everything we could and that would just
fix a
fraction of the problem just a fraction
90 companies have produced two thirds of
heat trapping gas emissions since the
dawn of the industrial era
okay so you want to pull the plug on 90
companies
not not just that we need we need
system-wide change
and a lot some of those companies are
already starting to change thanks to
pressure
some of them might not change and
they're going to have to go the way of
the horses and buggies
but we need system-wide change but a
system is made up of individuals
so that's why we have to take it we have
to take a quick break
but when we come back in just moments uh
catherine i want you to
pursue what it is that we need to do
about climate change and the way is
climate change is influencing our
behavior
the way it should or isn't or can
influence our behavior
so this is star talk live on facebook
and youtube
end of segment one back to segment two
let's see what he did there
that was that's a long break welcome to
welcome to segment two of star talk live
we are in the virtual coronaverse
right now and this whole uh subject is
on climate change
and i know a little bit about climate
change but not as much as any expert we
would
bring to the table such as who do we
have we have well we have more come
who else do we have coming in on this
segment dr peter mahaffey will be here
as well
okay and so we've got catherine hey ho
thank you again catherine
uh and your canadian accent is charming
let me just say
i know you're trying to hide it but you
can't it's it's there
for all of us to hear but but
uh tell me something um do you
how realistic is it to just simply
change everybody's behavior well the
first thing we have to change is not our
behavior
the first thing we have to change is the
way we think about the problem
because it turns out even though the
headlines are all about people who
reject science
when you actually look at the polling
data our real problem
is that we don't think it matters to us
and we don't think we can fix it
so that is why go ahead no no no no
it's very nice of you to anticipate what
i'm going to say but you have the floor
you keep talking
all right so that is why i have become
absolutely convinced
after years and years of working in this
that the number one thing
anybody can do is use their voice to
talk about why it matters to us
and the places where we live in ways
that matter to us as people
and what we can do to fix it which
includes individual solutions like step
on the carbon scale measure your carbon
footprint figure out things you can do
but talk about how big corporations are
going carbon neutral like microsoft and
even walmart and apple talk about how
cities
are cutting their carbon emissions and
meeting the paris agreement targets like
the city of houston where all the big
oil and gas companies live
uh talk about how clean energy is
revolutionizing the lives of poor people
who don't have access to affordable
electricity
talk about how carbon farming puts
carbon back in the soil
increases our soil health and our yields
and helps farmers be part of the
solution
use your voice to advocate for change at
your school
at your place of work at your
organization at your city in your family
using our voice most powerful thing we
can do all right so that's that's
hopeful and and that's what we're doing
here right with this
with this star talk live uh featuring
your voice
your canadian captain marvel uh as you
are
tell us um uh the fact that ever that
fewer people are traveling now
uh the coronavirus lockdown has what has
that
done to the climate so it has reduced
our emissions in april global carbon
emissions dropped by 17 percent around
the whole world
and they dropped by 25 earlier in china
as the lockdown happened there first and
they're still a little bit lower than
average because people aren't flying
that's great news but as the lockdown
passes they're just starting to go right
back up to where they work
well you don't think there's some habits
that we've accumulated uh because it's
way easier to do this
virtually than everybody get up and get
in a car and go to a theater i mean do
you think something to be some lingering
bits of this that that would keep i
think that there definitely will be
but the bulk of it was industry not you
and i flying or traveling that's only
about three percent of total emissions
here's the positive thing though
to meet the paris target which we were
talking about before we have to reduce
our global carbon emissions about 45
by 2030 and that sounded like an almost
impossible goal last year
well you know what we got almost halfway
there in three weeks in april
right okay okay so that's it's as he's
saying math it's an existence proof
it's oh my gosh you think we can't do
what we kind of already did
okay we had a proof of concept
exactly and went back up again so we
just have to realize that we can do it
we can bring them back down permanently
not temporarily
so let me go ahead you go no more come
on yeah i was going to say
so with respect to what you were talking
about with all of us
using our voice which i think is
excellent from i think the yale
climate communication study said that uh
somewhere around 54 percent of people
basically say they don't talk about it
at all they just don't even ever talk
about it
so it's extremely powerful but don't you
also think that
if we are doing something personally
that that makes you vested in the
problem
and being vested in the problem makes
you want to see
other people take action and it also
makes you want to
hold corporations and and
leaders authorities uh accountable
yes absolutely so the social science has
found that our sense of efficacy in
other words if we feel
empowered to act that has a tremendous
impact and also
even our sense of righteous anger look
i'm doing everything i can and look at
you you're doing nothing
i forgot such a term he's just righteous
anger that's like good trouble you know
it's one of those kind of things
i i hear it every every saturday when
i'm laying on the couch
what get out mow the lawn look i'm doing
everything i
off the ledge right there so so captain
tell me about the wildfires
that are that devastated australia
recently and of course
are doing so much damage in california
so wildfires are one of these things we
talked about where we're loading the
dice we've always had wildfires
in the u.s most of them are human
ignition most are accidental not arson
just to be clear
and up in canada and alaska they're
mostly just human ignition
is not always um malevolent is what
you're saying
no only seven percent big fires in
california were actual deliberate arson
most of them were as we now know gender
reveal pyrotechnics gone wrong
or people dumping burning trash into dry
brush
or just having something plugged in in
the shed that shorted out and started to
shed on fire
or power lines sparking that's what
starts most of the wildfires
okay i didn't know that so uh can you
trace a thread from the
wildfires to climate change absolutely
once they start
they're burning greater area and the
reason why they're burning greater area
is because the vegetation is dried out
the difference is imagine you throw a
match on a pile of pretty green wood
what happens then imagine you show that
you throw the same size match on a pile
of bone dry kindling what happens
a conflagration happens that's the
difference between climate change versus
not climate change
wow all right so i'm still trying to
figure something out here if
you just say things dried out climate
change they dried out
aren't there places that are getting
more rain than ever before
you know tell that to a place that just
had a huge flood so we are
simultaneously
as a scientific community saying yep
it's dry over there that's climate
change
yep it's wet over there that's climate
change um
and so people i don't think they have a
sense
of some directed phenomenon
that is itself increasing so how do you
reconcile that
you're absolutely right and the point of
connection the invisible point of
connection
is the fact that we're invisible
invisible
special glasses to see
what scientists said there's this
invisible thing you just got to believe
me
right no we can't measure it we can
measure it we just can't see it
okay it's the fact that the warmer the
atmosphere the more
water vapor it can hold so in other
words
the warmer it gets the more it dries out
our soils
and in dry areas like california our
vegetation
but when a storm comes along there's
more water vapor up there for that storm
to pick up and dump on us
so in a place that gets lots of storms
they're getting a lot of heavy rainfall
events
in a place where they don't get storms
all that water is evaporating and it's
just being transported out of the region
leaving it drier than what before before
it's the exact same mechanism in both
cases so these are related phenomena
the flooding and the droughts yes okay
and tell me about a sea level rise
because that's
um anytime i'm asked about climate
change that's what i think about the
most
because most of the world's great cities
are on the water's edge
historically of course for commerce and
transportation and
irrigation and the like on rivers for
example so
so sea level rise um
how does climate change give you that
and who gets affected first
so remember we talked about how the
we're wrapping an extra blanket around
the planet that's trapping grandma's
doing that yeah yes
over 90 of the heat being trapped by
that blanket is going into the
ocean so when we're using thermometers
to measure global air temperature global
warming we are literally measuring the
tip of the iceberg
and 93 of that iceberg is under the
ocean
okay just to be clear you're talking
about the heat energy
not the temperature so if so
if the ocean goes up by a fraction of a
degree
much smaller than two degrees celsius
that is an enormous amount of heat
energy
as a repository is that correct
exajoules
yes what's that word
what does that word mean it means a lot
of jewels excuse me exa as in the metric
prefix exa
jules as in the unit of energy and
thank you okay i thought that was a new
hip word that i didn't know about
okay it's it's what it's what all the
kids are using
okay so so this kilo mega
giga exa these are the metric prefixes
and there you go okay
yeah yeah again so chuck chuck
uh lou uh your buddy another
astrophysicist
did a calculation that i'm going to
screw up so i don't want to say it but
he did the calculation of the warming of
the oceans how much energy they are
holding and it ended up being
like i don't know 100 atomic bombs
the equivalent of something like that no
what he did was he made the
he calculated and i was going to like
verify this so that we can then go
public with that number
how generally you do that when you're
scientist and you guys were arguing
about it so now i could just say it
i'm just saying so you can ask how many
atomic bombs would you have to detonate
in the atmosphere to raise
the temperature two degrees as we have
done or be rated at one degree
what is that and that but we know atomic
bombs and everything else feels a little
more
sort of nebulous so so catherine in your
business of bringing this to the public
you are just chock full of examples such
as that right you
because otherwise people can't wrap
their head around the pure science
typically that you
that would otherwise be delivered no we
can't put we're not used to processing
numbers like that like 10 to the 21 what
does that even mean
but what matters though is because 10 to
21 that's how many
gigawatts was in the flux capacitor
everybody knows that oh my god
with you
yeah it was actually gigawatts but they
said gigawatts because it's a movie but
that's fine
um wait so let me ask another thing
kevin
some decades ago one of the news weekly
magazines back when people read things
on paper uh it had a it had a headline
um
ice age coming okay
so tell me about these calculations that
talked about ice ages either in the past
that would be imminent or uh ice ages
that
might have been scheduled for the future
and now will be delayed
isn't that a good thing yes because we
humans don't like it too cold or too hot
we like it
just right so in celestial mechanics
class
which you probably took too we learned
about the
orbital cycles of the earth orbit around
the sun
and how they alter the way that the
sun's energy falls on the earth and
those are actually responsible for
the ice ages or what we scientists call
the glacial maxima
and then the warm periods like we're in
today but because they are predictable
we can calculate where we are on that
cycle and here's where we are
oh this is good
we know that there was an ice age about
twenty thousand years ago we know that
it ended when a rodent went looking for
an acorn and broke off a chunk of ice no
that's that's
exactly what happened in in the movie
ice age that is a that is a documentary
and you were probably there filming it
right i did have a cameo
in ice age 5. i have a cameo on ice age
5.
i have to quickly tell you one of the
reviews of ice age 5 was uh it said
this is evidence that it's about time
the franchise goes extinct
so there hasn't been an ice age six i'm
sorry so
anyhow back two go right so where are we
on this cycle it was an ice age
we got warmer warming peaked about six
to eight thousand years ago
right around the dawn of human
civilization and agriculture even
in agriculture because we had the
perfect climatic conditions
and then since then temperature was very
very gradually slowing and cooling very
gradually
but agriculture and deforestation had
pretty much
stabilized it so we had pretty much hit
the sweet spot
and then the industrial revolution
happened and we're going straight in the
opposite direction
so the official conclusion is is that
the next glacial maximum
would have happened in about 1500 years
give or take a few hundred years
but in fact we have indefinitely delayed
it for not just thousands but probably
tens of thousands of years
and not only are we we don't we want to
be stable but we're not stable we are
headed
in the other direction faster than any
time in the history of human
civilization on this planet
okay that's something we should be in a
cooling period is what you're saying
because we said
we should be going down that's what
she's saying so so
yeah tell that to la when it was 120
degrees a couple of weeks ago
um so it was in pasadena any somewhere
in
the valley uh so let me let me ask you i
i
i leapfrogged over one of my questions
which was about sea level rise
because tell me what's the is it just
melting of land glaciers
is that all that's happening there right
so about half of sea level rise is
because warmer water takes up more space
and all of that extra heat is going to
the ocean the other half is the melting
of land-based ice
not arctic sea ice because arctic sea
ice is already sitting on
the water like ice cubes in your glass
when the ice cubes melt your glass
doesn't overflow
but what's happening now is that
sea level is rising twice as fast as
when the satellite observations began 25
years ago
and that is because greenland and
antarctica are melting
much faster than they used to be and the
reason we care about it like you said is
because
two-thirds of the largest cities in the
world are located within just a few feet
or a meter of sea level
and about 700 million people
live in the low elevation coastal zone
so we just have to pick up cities and
move them inland and then
that's all it's like a superman movie
just you know
it's like hey just buy my property in
camden new jersey
instead of the jersey shoreline because
that's going to be beats from property
one day you're talking about superman
the move the original was that the
original movie yeah you're going way
back chuck that's like oh it was lex
luthor that's all i remember
there's been more than one of them
recurring
they're all one movie to me they're all
one movie
um so uh what are the first uh so cities
will obviously get hit
but i've read about whole countries in
um or land masses
in this in the south pacific or in the
uh western pacific region of the world
where whole countries are just a few
feet above sea level so they'll just be
gone
if this continues yes and they're
already trying to immigrate but
unfortunately climate refugee is not an
official designation
for a refugee under the united nations
you work for the u.n
change it i don't know
you're a car carrying you in person i
didn't give me a card i'm telling you no
cape no cards
no card no superpowers big large piece
of glass
that's it um so so
uh unfortunately so new zealand for
example is taking a handful of people a
year they have a quota
but they're not taking nearly enough
people to move the entire population
and even so losing your country even if
you could transport your entire family
which most people are not yet able to do
even if you could transport your whole
community you're still losing your
country and that is something that's
part of you
yeah so so
suppose you could you live inland and
you're just selfish you say okay i live
in the colorado rockies
i don't care about changing uh sea
levels
a lot of people i think who feel that
way so what do you what do you do
when you confront them climate change is
the great threat multiplier
it takes whatever issue you're currently
dealing with wherever you live and it
makes it worse
so if i talk to people in colorado i
talk about their snowpack
warmer winters less snow also
heavy floods in between crazy floods oh
so the snowpack just because i'm a city
guy so let me see if i understand that
so you expect a certain amount of snow
during the winter that stays up on the
tops of mountains and you're skiing and
other
winter sports and then in the spring the
snow melts and it's a supply of water
down into your valley or whatever
surrounds the mountain and that balance
that ecosystem
is something that's been honed for
thousands of years is that a fair
interpretation of what you just said not
to mention the depletion of aquifers you
also have
um you also have tourism people go to
colorado to ski
you're not going to be able to do that
who wants to skin you on on
grass
and i'm black i'm black and i don't even
and i know that
yeah i've actually done that in colorado
and it's mud
and not to mention
well come on seriously you know i don't
know and it's
damn cold and that's all that's all i
know about skiing
okay talk to our winters protect our
winters needs to take you
and take you scheming and you can both
talk about climate change together
yeah well it'll be a data point in our
lives yes i'm all happy to talk about
climate change with them
in the lodge in the lodge to the fire
with a brandy in my hand
isn't climate change
you got to leave us some hope here
because you you're just saying we're all
going to die
and what what's that and you can't just
say let's keep talking yes you did say
that and
yes i appreciate it and embrace it but
give me something to go into the next
segment with
so that we're all not just completely
bummed out right now this is what you
should do just go
neal i got nothing and i'm out
that would be the most awesome ending
ever
i am on my way to the launch pad for
elon musk's ship to mars
just kidding uh no there is hope and
that's actually what i said
right that'd be funny chuck if she's
saying no here's what you should do
as she's sort of backing out the back
door and then there's the spaceship
waiting for her
to evacuate see a spacex band picking
her up
absolutely so i i'm
compelled to say just right now that
mars is well
antarctica is balmier
and wetter than any place on mars
so mars would not really be the first
place you'd think of going
i'd rather fix earth just so you know i
completely agree with you in fact
um one of the previous times we saw each
other was at the starmus festival
in i forgot about that yeah up in norway
in a
city i can't pronounce but it was in
norway
thank you thank you and so stephen
hawking gave one of his very last talks
there before he passed away and of
course he spoke a lot about the risks
and dangers of climate change but then
he said
we might just have to terraform mars and
i'm sitting there thinking are you
insane because there is no way we have
time to terraform mars
and get large numbers of people there
before climate change overtakes our
civilization
no no you just climate you just
terraform it fast right
it would be a lot easier to fix climate
change right
no no mike you know what my rebuttal is
to that oh do you tell me
it's a rebuttal okay okay i think it's a
strong rebuttal and the chuck i want to
get you
dumbass
here it is because i you know i live in
a real world a practical world and i'd
like practical solutions to practical
problems
not imagine solutions that we wish were
true
consider that if we had the power
of geoengineering to turn mars into
earth
then we have the power of geoengineering
to turn earth back into earth
just chew on that yeah that's a very
good point and i would say so
therefore let's terraform mars and ship
a billion people there
no terraform earth but if you can do
that to mars you can do it to earth
without fighting that's so wrong yeah
and and you can't without side effects
that's the thing it's like giving
everybody a
vaccine for coronavirus that hasn't even
gone through stage two
testing that's what geoengineering the
planet is like today well at the moment
at the moment
i think it has a i think it has a
fertile future
for saving us from ourselves um and
because often engineering problems are
the solution rather than changing the
behavior
of a billion people i mean that's hard
to do well here's here's the hope
i want to leave you with hope and then
you need to talk to peter because he's
got lots of good stuff to say yes yes we
have another guest coming in in the
third segment
the hope is this and this is what i
study i study the future
and i look at the different choices that
we as a civilization make
and i can tell you that there is a world
of difference between
a scenario where we just keep on using
fossil fuels the way we have for 300
years
versus a scenario where you transition
to clean energy number one
we are much more efficient half of us
carbon emissions we could get rid of
them just by being more efficient and
saving money
and then also some lifestyle choices too
which just makes sense
and let me tell you this when a new
iphone comes out
do people say oh you really should get
it you have to get it it's better for
you if you get it no everybody lines up
to get it because it is better
so technology does have a place and
people are lining up to get things like
electric cars and solar panels and cool
things and we've got solar paint and
solar roads as well our bike paths and
wind turbines and mini wind turbines but
we've also got efficiency that saves
money we've got things that actually
have short-term benefits as well as
long-term ones
and short-term benefits can change
people's minds and so our choices
absolutely matter today more than ever
and we can make a difference
and one person truly can be that agent
of change
wow good job since you just say we have
to all stop having kids and become
vegans you just said that i am all about
that
you do not have to tell me not to have
any children
believe me i am so on that train i am
i'm the chuck has three
no no so catherine your your your your
comments are wise
and sage and uh i so there is some hope
even if it's not unfolding on the time
scale that we seek
perhaps it'll maybe we need a few more
disasters to to make people sit up a
little
higher in their chairs perhaps because
we tend to be better at reacting to a
problem then preventing one
in advance i think uh the history of
american behavior
in the world so um but
okay i because you're on the front lines
and if you tell us to have hope i
i don't know who else to believe but you
active hope
not just passive it'll all turn out okay
in the end because it won't a fast step
i hope we have
we have to have out of realistic hope
none of that jesse jackson hope
people alive
what you're saying is because i've i
don't like the word hope
because it's what you express when you
confess that you're not in control oh i
just hope
but so the fact that you've now put a
nuance on it this passive hope which is
what i just described
an act of hope all right i have hope
that this will change and i'm doing
something to enable that
yes we will end segment two on that
positive thought by catherine catherine
it's delight to have you again
on star talk we will continue to reach
for you um
because this this has not ended i mean
you do get a card carrying u.n
id you know tell us then then
then we can hold you to it with whatever
u.n says you go back and read on the
right act
okay or catherine don't worry just email
me i'll i know some people that can make
you one
mm-hmm
chuck you got people like that i got
different kind of people
all right catherine thanks for joining
star talk live thank you for having me
i'm going to visit you all on facebook
and drop a few links into the chat if
people want more
definitely do so all right so
let's go right into segment three this
is star talk live we're talking about
the science of climate
uh the sociology of people's reaction to
climate change all of the above and
we're in collaboration
with pocket lab who helps us bring this
to you
live on facebook and uh
where else will be streaming facebook
and youtube
youtube course youtube of course
so coming into this segment we're going
to talk about climate chemistry
yes citizen science and who's going to
join us for that because
again you know i know a little bit but
not enough like the experts know
let's bring in peter mahaffey peter
welcome
back to star talk it's fabulous to be
here
neil chuck excellent you're professor of
chemistry at king's university in
alberta
canada that's right director of the king
center for
visualization and science and with the
special focus on
climate change science and awareness
you're the guy
you're if so if all this fails it's your
fault
if the attempt to change the world
because you're you are that's your title
that's on your business card well people
have been blaming chemists for a long
time neil so uh
later on
so so through the lens of a chemist how
do you think about and study climate
change
yeah that's a great question you know
your audience is probably sitting there
thinking you're bringing a chemist on
what do things do well they bring us
toxic substances and pollutants and
smoke coming out of exhausts
but i want to know peter some of my best
friends are made of chemicals
i don't know about you but that's true
for me yeah yeah i want to plant a
different
a different image in in the minds of
your listeners and viewers and that's
i think of chemists as caretakers or
stewards of matter and energy
and uh think about climate and climate
change climate is regulated by matter
and energy flowing through
our atmosphere cryosphere oceans and
land
and chemists transform and analyze
substances
we understand the flow of energy and
chemical reactions and
processes so even though chemists don't
pay
nearly enough attention to that climate
change is right in our wheelhouse
and we need to both talk about it a lot
more as catherine heyo was saying
we also need to do a lot more about it
let me give you an example
everybody knows about carbon dioxide
right carbon dioxide formed from
fossil fuels that were laid down maybe
hundreds of millions of years ago
uh they've been there and now in the
last 250 years we've extracted them at
dramatic rates we're burning them or
making co2 simple combustion reaction
and that's changing the energy of our
planet in a short period of time so
that's that's chemistry that we
understand and control and it makes our
life a lot better
but there's other chemistry too there's
greenhouse gases like
methane and nitrous oxide and
fluorinated gases
and physicists pay attention to isotopes
in antarctic ice that
tell us what the temperature was a long
time ago and
the best of all of this is that that
knowledge is now
followed by the things that chemistry is
doing at the
forefront to develop new technologies to
tackle climate change
okay that's so that means you can help
us
here you're not just some chemist in a
lab
even though you know what's going on you
can actually uh
be inventive and innovative to help this
cause
that's right it's all about
understanding so that we can do
something about it and then it's helping
to provide the materials and reactions
and new ways of
thinking about transforming materials in
order to mitigate climate change and you
know there's
there's new carriers for fuel hydrogen
and ammonia there's fuel cells there's
the materials for solar cells and wind
turbines
chemists are working hard to create new
ways of fixing nitrogen to feed the
world
you know chuck went chuck when peter
started talking when he said you know
we we command all of matter and energy
that was like the beginning of a
superhero movie well basically yeah he's
somebody's nemesis somebody superhero
nemesis in the making
here if you think about it chemist or
thanos
i mean that's basically what don't let
peter snap
at you you know i love the metaphor neil
of
caretakers or stewards right we have
these powerful tools
and we need to learn how to use them in
a way that uh that's green and
sustainable and helps to build a
better future for people and for our
planet so what do what do you think in
terms
of as you said uh you know
uh chemical companies may be seen as
part of the problem
and we've had this conversation where
you say chemical companies make what
people demand
so you know we're part of that problem
too
but can they be part of the solution
and how would that be can is there a
will that look yeah what would that look
like if if we were to use chemistry as a
way out
yeah absolutely and there's a huge
change but
can i just butt in for a second i just
since it's not often i'm in arm's reach
of a chemist
just before you answer that question
back off a little bit
don't you just let them near your neck
peter don't let them near your neck
list for me the greenhouse gases
that are in the atmosphere and that
exists so that i have a full
understanding
because when you come at us and say
here's here's what we can do to fix this
or that
presumably some solutions are best for
some greenhouse gases relative to others
so just give me that quick inventory
yeah for sure the only one that gets any
airplay is carbon dioxide right and it's
all about c
well that's for good reason it's the
most important greenhouse gas and it's
something that we can do a lot about
and we're doing a lot about but right
behind that neil
are our methane gas ch4 there's
nitrous oxide laughing gas who would
have thought that's a major contributor
to climate change
and then where does that where does that
come from and so why can't i get more of
that in my life
and you talk about a
methane this is like cow flatulence
right that's right you know that's a
contributor methane one of the
contributors are
agriculture including intensive
agriculture
but methane comes from uh from anaerobic
fermentation the stuff that happens in
rice fields and patties it comes
landfill termites too termites termites
producing large amounts of methane oil
and gas
operations that aren't my uncle daryl
daryl uncle daryl
contributor he's a big source of methane
on the catalyst
it's present at a lot lower
concentrations than carbon dioxide but
it's about at least 30 to 70 times as
powerful a greenhouse gas as
as carbon dioxide is a molecule for
molecule molecule per molecule
and so it's a good thing there isn't as
much of it in our atmosphere but then
then you go to the third one on the list
which is laughing gas and here you're
thinking oh
dentists right they're they're making
all of their patients relaxed and
they're i do it this is the source of
all our problems
the other place that you might think
about with laughing gas is if you go to
the store and you get some whipping
cream and that little spurt that you
were on here on your pump when you put
it on your pumpkin pie that's laughing
gas but
but the real sources of it and and
they're i'm not giving up my whipped
cream i'm sorry
well flood the world take us into it
it's not a big contributor but it's
growing the pumpkins for your pumpkin
pie that's the problem neil because
it's when we over apply fertilizers and
uh bacteria in the soil end up doing
nitrification and denitrification
processes that turn all of that extra
ammonia
and and and nitrate urea fertilizers
into laughing gas and it's such
agriculture agriculture agriculture is a
big contributor
and it lasts for it's about 300 times
the global warming potential of carbon
dioxide molecule for molecule
and nothing happens to it in the
atmosphere it doesn't dissolve in water
it doesn't break down in chemical
reactions so it's a big player
and then the third one the last one on
that list behind
carbon dioxide are the fluorinated gases
things like the cfcs and so on
you put all three of those together and
they add up to about
two thirds to three quarters of the
change that's happened to our planet's
radiation balance since the industrial
revolution there are
recent cfcs as a chemist okay you're
fluent
but for everybody else those are the
score fluorocarbons correct
so these are it's cfcs these are
molecules that are made of carbon atoms
and fluorine and chlorine atoms
only and then they've been replaced with
ones that aren't as damaging to the
ozone layer but there's other
fluorinated compounds too where we put
fluorine atoms on carbon
and whenever you do that they last a
long time in the atmosphere and they
absorb a
huge amount of infrared radiation that
would otherwise escape our planet and uh
go into
it so can i ask you when you talk about
methane which is far more powerful than
carbon dioxide
carbon dioxide partly
um when we're when we talk about losing
the permafrost and you talk about the
melting
of glaciers that that
means that we're going to have a
crapload more of methane in the
atmosphere right
tell me about the permafrost let's hear
that story so there's there's two places
where we have
a lot of methane naturally stored on our
planet and uh one of them
well three places of course is deep
underground in oil and gas fields but
we have a lot of methane stored in the
permafrost up in the
polar regions and uh some of it's pretty
deep down and then we have methane
stored in molecules that are called
clathrate hydrates they're kind of
locked in cages of water molecules off
of ocean
open shelves and when we get to the the
polar regions like the arctic
and we start seeing climate change
happening and if we get
a change in temperature of a couple of
degrees average
around the planet that translates into 8
to 10 degrees
celsius increase at the poles and what
happens we start getting
uh what catherine talked about a
positive feedback loop and positive
doesn't mean a good thing
uh that the the temperature warms up it
doesn't take much energy to release that
methane gas
and then we get one of these feedback
loops going where the methane gas
powerful greenhouse gas causes more
local warming causes more permafrost
melting
and that's probably been one of the
phenomena that has happened
at other times in our earth's history
when we've gone through mass extinctions
we've maybe had a
a mere hit the planet and released a lot
of methane from clathrate hydrates
chuck did you have casually he said that
yeah exactly yeah it's kind of happening
you know you know our other mass
extinctions
you know those those other things that
happened
you know there was a time when a meteor
hit the planet that didn't go so well
yeah yeah it's just another time we used
to have these things called dinosaurs
you know we might join them we might
join them who knows
but you know that's what makes this
climate crisis so serious right the
effect that it has on biodiversity
the effect that it has on on human life
but also
our whole planet's life and and we're
risking
entering another mass extinction because
we can't seem to manage
that problem of greenhouse gases so
what's the biggest challenge
and given your chemical expertise what
are the biggest opportunities
that you see in front of us to mitigate
climate change
yeah so so you know the two big
challenges are that
the climate crisis is so serious and
it's on such an
urgent timeline that we feel inadequate
as humans and we become
paralyzed and and i think another
equally big challenge is that
politics has hijacked the climate
conversation in really
unfortunate ways so you know carbon
dioxide molecules in the atmosphere
don't vote conservative or liberal or
republican or democrat they don't expect
national boundaries
and yet the gases that we met in north
america for instance
affect life in really profound ways for
people
in other parts of the world who don't
emit many greenhouse gases
so we've got to find ways to understand
each other to move beyond our
nationalist agendas and work
together to become caretakers of the
planet okay
so it's easy to say how are you going to
make it happen
yeah well there's a a little
visualization that uh maybe lindsay can
pop up on the screen uh one of the
things we've
done at our king center for
visualization and science is to
to work over the last two years to
create an
interactive learning resource it's
called design our climate
and it's something that your users can
can go to it's going to encourage them
to
to envision the future to design future
emission scenarios by making informed
choices about electricity transportation
landings building materials
and what do you find when you do that
first of all that if you use
currently available technologies you can
get
to our target of one and a half degrees
celsius
it's tough it requires fundamental
changes but the other thing you find is
there's no silver bullet there's not one
new magic technology that we can impose
that's going to make it happen
i like to say there's silver buckshot
there's a whole bunch of things
that we can do and we can do them
together and they will make a difference
so yeah that that's a resource that i
think
uh your listeners might find pretty
helpful
that uh i'd never heard a firearms
analogy uttered by a canadian
before yeah it makes sense it's like
silver but we
all we have to do now is uh shoot
climate crisis in the face
that's what we have to do so so um
what do you know about the the blue sky
zero um
citizen science initiative what is that
yeah that's fantastic this is an
initiative of pocket lab who's uh
co-sponsoring this uh
event uh and uh pocket lab makes uh a
bunch of sensors air sensors
uh water sensors uh instruments for
citizen science
and uh my team at the visualization
center up in edmonton uh partnered with
uh pocket lab
over the last year and uh we've been
helping
launch a program called blue sky zero
get a bunch of air quality
sensors in the hands of citizens from
around the world
and then see if they can measure air
quality
during the shutdown and then as we
emerge from the shutdown can we actually
measure
significant changes in air pollutants
and and so
that pilot was really successful it
showed us that we can do it
we can get data back to scientists who
can begin to make sense of it
and now the challenge is can we roll out
some citizen science initiatives on a
much bigger scale to
help all sorts of people understand and
feel like they can own
their understanding for some of these
big challenges wait peter i have a
better idea
figure out a way go back to your
chemistry lab now figure out a way how
to
color tag carbon dioxide molecules
so that any time you drive your car
you'll see it coming out
into the air and because it's all
invisible all of it
yeah and if you can't see it they don't
think it's there and they're not
then it's not an active thought when you
see plumes of
soot coming out of trucks and cars we we
fixed it took a while but we fixed that
all right and so uh can't you tag
molecules and make them visible or at
least temporarily
the only problem with that is it'll
become a fashion statement
we're we're such idiots that you'll see
people just be like
oh yeah i i i went with i went with a
green
green with my my outfit
right you know or if or if you
color-coded methane
you would know who dealt it now that i'm
in favor of
yeah hey you know what are you gonna say
if i if i
tell you that we can do that already
but it's not what you're thinking so you
know the big problem we have with these
greenhouse gases is that you walk
outside and you can see some air
pollutants right maybe this guy's brown
or it's hazy from forest fires
but the greenhouse gases that are
causing climate change are colorless
they're interacting with invisible
radiation in the infrared region
spectrum so
we don't understand what's going on but
if you put on the glasses of a chemist
you know what you can do
you can color them with looking at their
isotopes so some carbon atoms are carbon
12 atoms and some are carbon 13 and you
know what you can do
you can actually tell whether the carbon
dioxide over a city
or over a nation is actually coming from
industrial processes through their
isotope ratios or whether it's coming
from natural sources so
yeah it's not quite as nice as violet
carbon dioxide molecules
but if you put on a mass spectrometer
set of glasses you can
you can look at them and that's a pretty
cool tool well you know what so
i'm gonna give me one of those i would
love a mass spectrometer
but the cool thing about that is has has
anyone done that from an imaging
standpoint i think it would be very
powerful
to show people the images of where they
live in their communities
and to be able to see the air quality
where they live
chuck we did a little bit of that we did
a visualization of that for one of the
episodes of cosmos
where we tried to show how different the
world would look if you had access to
those
sort of visual tools
um but you know it's one thing to show
it in
with computer graphics there's another
thing for it to be real yeah
yeah yeah yeah so peter get back to work
on this yeah we're on it and i love
chuck's idea there's a project yeah
absolutely
it's super cool so oh so there's a plan
to
i see the um the occasional uh slide
come up
did you fully explain the slides as you
needed no i just want
30 seconds with that slide that just
popped up go ahead
lindsey so um we're absolutely thrilled
neil to announce
today on star talk that uh we're
releasing
unleashing on the world of a free
interactive electronic resource to use
to help understand what the status of
our life support systems
is and the extent we which human
activity is flattening in it's called
the planetary boundaries framework some
of you are going to know something about
it
you can see that so what we see is just
a a frame shot
but it's actually an interactive tool
it's a live interactive tool that went
live last night at about midnight and
you can look at all nine earth systems
you can see how their
uh control variables change over time
you can
click on them and get a bunch of
information about what you can do about
them
we think it's going to be a really
powerful tool to help with climate
change understanding and how it's linked
to all of the other earth systems
because climate change
looks like an awesome teaching tool of
course it is yeah yes
yeah because then you can walk people
through it and then they become
uh then they can take that to others
once they become sort of fluent in it
and what it means and where it's going
to take you so so what what
what thoughts of hope do you have for us
here
before we go to our q a hope you know
it's got to be active hope but
what brings me hope neil is is two
things i
i'm really privileged to work locally in
a learning community
and and these days teaching chemistry
every day when i go in i see my students
with masks and
face shields on and they're trying in
the middle of all of these challenges to
live out our university's vision
statement which is
help to build a more just humane and
sustainable planet
and they're doing it you know our
world's in good hands with these young
people
but then i also work at that's because
they're all canadians
duh you know that's just that you get
that for free
she didn't work to get that we take part
in me and please a lot then and you know
pardon me for the way our planet isn't
working and please let us help do
something about it
um but then the other thing that brings
me hope is that i do a lot of work at
global levels in science and science
education space and
and there is a lot of momentum about
doing science education
differently so that we think about
systems we get away from isolated facts
we think about sustainability and so
uh we can find ways to do science to do
education as if
people matter and as if our planet
matters and that gives me a lot of hope
yeah but peter i think that's that's a
great perspective and thought
and sentiment but what at what's at the
center of what you're saying
is that um it's not just the knowledge
that something is happening
there's the understanding of why it's
happening and that requires a level of
science literacy that you are
championing here
do you do you have hope for the world if
the world does not achieve the science
literacy
you think they might need to really
um embrace the problem science
just be a superficial thing that they
heard about at the coffee
lounge you know if chemistry keeps being
taught the way it's been taught for the
last hundred years where it's a whole
bunch of isolated facts that you
memorize and
then then it's hopeless but that's not
happening there's
fundamental change happening in science
education and it is focused on
systems thinking it's focused on
sustainability and it's it's
it's it's a train that's moving there's
no way that train's stopping now you see
it in the next generation science
standards in the us you see it in
in science and sustainability
initiatives you see chemists and
scientists working with people in
humanities and social sciences and the
fine arts
we're on the train and it's it's moving
that's a very 19th century reference
there on a train
see an astrophysic we're on a rocket and
we're going fast
okay just consider using a more updated
we're writing a children's story about
getting a train over a mountain from uh
from venice which is flooding to paris
and we're asking kids to think about
what
locomotive is going to take them there's
a way of talking about okay
so trains are in my mind yeah it's
thomas the tank engine told by account
yeah yeah we got that well peter thank
you for this
uh sharing this expertise can you hang
on for q a sure
yeah excellent excellent so let's go to
the uh final part of this live
uh this star talk live on climate change
the science the sociology
the um the the citizen science part of
this
uh it's all it's all one thing and
to now turn it to the q a we'll get to
know what all of you are thinking many
of you are science teachers
because you're in the the pool of people
who
know about and support pocket labs
mission as do we so
um that's great so peter thanks for
staying on and i want to introduce
someone
who's actually collating the questions
for this segment
and that's dave baker dave are you there
i am here can you excellent excellent
it's great to be doing this again with
you
yeah great to see you guys yeah your
co-founder of pocket lab
will brag on you a bit here co-founder
of pocket lab
and a teacher and a mentor at stanford
university
in the graduate school of engineering so
you got some good engineering chops
uh behind that and you've been
collecting questions uh i just whole
time i have
i have we've then we've gotten thousands
of questions so thousands yeah so let's
start now and we'll see
so hopefully you're not tired get some
coffee we'll be over here by tuesday
right
so i think so um okay
if a good one comes up we'll try to grab
it out of the chat but um
okay yeah and you're delivering all the
questions is that correct just for
efficiency
okay good i got them all i got them all
and if you can identify who said the
question there because i will
give you a shout out so you know i have
the first question just dives right into
some of the stuff you've been talking i
think this would be a good summary
and this is a question is from india and
it's from shiva mishra
and the question is is global warming
really caused by humans
earth is warmed and cold before when
there are no humans
and the amount of co2 released by humans
is less compared to other sources
so it's really interesting to hear you
know a skeptical question from india
right
yeah yeah peter what evidence you have
that is us either
yeah yeah yeah well it's more than the
chemists you know
uh but that's a great question dave and
and thank you for
uh for that question from india it's
it's a question a lot of people wrestle
with because if you look at data
that goes back and we've got really good
temperature data going back millions of
years but if you look at
the record that comes from ice cores
going back 800 000 years
what you see on those graphs of
temperature is that the
the temperature goes up and down over
that 800
000 years and sometimes we're in ice
ages and sometimes we come out of ice
ages the temperature may be
changes 10 degrees or something like
that in between those periods
and parallel with that correlated with
that are the concentrations of these
greenhouse gases
so what are we so worried about with a
degree and a half of warming over a
period of time
and so um to in order to address that we
created a uh an interactive resource
at kcbs.ca the visualization center
and it invites you to take all of that
data
and graph it and now go in and examine
the data
interrogated and ask some questions
about it don't tell people what to think
but
but look at the data can you have some
good questions and what you find is
if you go to one of the periods in the
last 800 000 years where the temperature
is going up the most steeply
and you measure the slope of that line
of temperature versus time
and then you compare it to the slope of
that line over the last 200 years
you find that one thing is different and
its rate of change
humans are causing the temperature to
change since the industrial revolution
at a rate we haven't seen before
and so yes it's it's that's what the big
difference maker is and that's what the
great acceleration is that's why we talk
about leaving the holocene epoch and
entering the anthropocene epoch where
our human bridge is fundamentally
changing
the life support systems of our earth
right so what you're saying is yeah
so if earth has been through this before
but just got into it a little more
slowly right so what's really going on
is we spent
thousands of years building what we're
calling civilization
on this sort of plateau of climate
stability
and so the the simple fact of climate
change is not itself a problem
it's that it's a climate change in the
face of a civilization
that's not built to anticipate climate
change is that a fair characterization
of this
yeah that's a great characterization and
then and then if you think about when
you know catherine hey was talking about
when human civilizations really began to
emerge and they're in the holocene and
when agriculture happened
and for most of the last 12 000 years we
haven't seen a change of more than about
one degree celsius
in the average surface temperature of
our planet and so
you know sometimes some people call that
sometimes the garden of eden it's a
place where humans can thrive and our
planet can thrive
and now what are we doing since the
industrial revolution we've gone up
almost one more degree since 1750 and
we're on a trajectory by the end of the
century to go up four or five or six if
we don't do anything about it
and if we do a whole bunch about it
maybe we can keep it below one and a
half or two degrees
so the deal is this is all measurable
number one
quantifiable and identifiable
it's us we are the we are the ones that
are doing it that's right
we are the ones we are the ones
we are the culprits
hi dave bring on another well let's get
to the data is this proverbial hockey
stick right
yeah yeah yeah um well you know and it's
funny that he's canadian so he really
thinks
by the way this is the you have to call
us the great white north edition
of star talk no no no dave
give me another one what do you have
yeah yeah so um here's a question this
is from vanessa turner of canada another
canadian
how do we how can we make climate change
education less preachy and more about
the data
are there places where teachers can
access climate data in
easy to process understand ways to use
in the classroom and allow them to
manipulate it it's
basically what you just show it but what
are the resources that can make this
more about the data less about the you
know you you better be good
that's about choosing signs yeah right
right well it's you know i was talking
about trying to de-politicize the
conversations and that is so
hard for teachers to do and uh all of us
know
that all you have to do with in
education is tell people what to think
and it works right
lots of examples of that in history that
doesn't work and when it comes to
something really controversial like
climate change what we've got to do is
find ways to
uh to give give students tools to
examine the data and ask really good
questions
and you know so that tool that i was
just telling you about to actually
measure the slope
of temperature over over 800 000 years
that's exactly the kind of thing that's
needed and there's
super good sources out there you'll find
references to a lot of these at kcds.ca
there's other really reliable sources
for teachers the national oceanic and
atmospheric administration in the states
and nasa
have incredible resources where you can
provide data to students and you can
help them ask really good questions
about it but of course people have to
know
they have to want to do that and so
often people just refuse up front
and then they just carry this
misinformation with them
and then further spread then it shows up
on political tracks
right i mean the challenge i i think
we're all gonna die
by the way by the way for those teachers
out there that's uh that's a great
lesson
there there you have it like that's let
that be lesson one
it's important to know that these tools
are out there whether or not you knew it
and i know about the nasa tools because
i'm closer to them
but all the rest of these tools peter
that you're listing there
um yeah and we'll make sure we have
accurate good links in the in the
uh when this finally post yeah all right
we've got about 10 minutes
left can uh let's see if we can get like
a bunch of get like a lightning round
maybe so we can get
through some of the thousands well i
have a this is a quick one for peter too
and then that's going to i got a great
lightning round questions for you is
there an experiment peter what's an
experiment like elementary or middle
school kids could do that
illustrates what's going on well there's
a lot of really basic ideas about
climate that you can introduce at that
level
and those ideas have to do with the
difference between climate and weather
which a whole bunch of adults don't seem
to know about but
kids can get that when they think about
you know the weather they experience
over a long period of time
that's climate and the weather they
experience day-to-day or
there's uh there's other things that
young students can do to begin to
understand
heat flow in our atmosphere you know
give them a little
uh infrared camera and have them start
looking at that infrared radiation that
they can't actually
see and boy they're puzzled by that and
then give them an idea that just like
light
uh visible light uh can be absorbed by
things like a colored solution that
infrared light from
from an infrared you know a little laser
that you can use to detect temperature
it's that interacting with these
invisible uh colorless gases
in the sky that's actually causing our
planet to uh to get
warmer and there's a model that can be
used when you get just a little further
in
with with kids maybe into middle school
that breaks down the problem of
our changing our the radiation balance
of our planet
into a couple of really simple um
parameters that you can actually change
and play with and you can change
the the temperature of our planet by
moving it closer or further from the sun
by changing the amount of light that
reflects off of white and bright
surfaces on our planet the albedo
and by changing the amount of greenhouse
gases and so again at kcbs.ca we've
built a little interactive simulation to
help
young kids play with that and uh it
really helps with understanding that
where were we adults too grown-ups yeah
absolutely
here here's here is what i learned from
that last answer
uh it is better to go to public school
in canada
where you can get an infrared camera
it's an infrared camera i'm like
give that to the eight-year-old kid not
in america
not in america
there's a lot of heat flowing but it's
mostly political right and it's
political
here a lot of hot air there you go dave
keep them coming you got a few more
minutes well these are these are some i
got some rapid fire questions for neil i
think most of these were directed at you
but you guys
might have some fun with these there's
some interesting ones here so from
arena ramen would you rather be an
expert in one thing or a novice at
everything
definitely an expert in one thing oh
because then you
spoken by the man who is an expert in
many things
shut up next question jesus
christ stop wasting the time
this guy this guy's an expert in so many
things he's like i'd much rather be an
expert in one thing
no no here's the thing no no i'll repeat
something i've said before
one of the big challenges in life is
knowing enough about something
to think you're right but not enough
about that same thing
to know that you're wrong oh yeah and we
have too much of that second case
influencing policy in this world so
i'd rather be in a sea of experts and if
i need an expert on something i'll go to
somebody else i don't need you to know
everything i've got somebody else who's
an expert in that
that's how i'd like to think about this
problem so and i've been married for 24
years
and so i know that i am not right about
anything
i want to i want to come back to you
neil about that in one specific way i
agree with you completely
and when it comes to teachers and
climate change
one of the biggest problems we have it's
problem i faced early in my career as a
chemist moving into climate change
education and that's
i'm not an expert climate scientist i'm
not catherine hayjo
and so we have teachers all around the
world saying i'm not an expert
so i can't teach climate change science
and so what we need to do
is find ways to get them resources to
get them working together
to to tell people when they don't know
something
but still to dig in there and make
connections to the things they teach
because otherwise the game's lost
and let me just say something very
quickly on top of that peter
uh climate change is such a a large a
problem that
no matter what you're an expert in
climate change touches it
so all you have to do is make the
connection to climate change where
you're an expert
that's right as i've done i just talked
about the runaway greenhouse effect on
venus
but i i live in new york city which is a
media capital news media
and i get called all the time could you
comment on the wildfires and the climate
change and this i said
no get a climate change expert they call
me because i think they're
lazy a little bit because they know they
know how to reach me and i'll give them
a good sound bite
and it's relevant i'd rather go back to
the rolodex
so what we need is more climate same
climate change
professionals out there reaching to the
public and i
i'm disappointed about that i don't see
more it's hard to see my own damn face
up there
talking about this here's what i love i
love the fact that neil
has this uh this this like
humility where he doesn't understand
they're calling you because
you're freaking neil degrasse tyson okay
and he does this let me tell you
something i've been working with neil
never
be their climate expert get him a
climate expert
okay but but the deal is this man
it's like who do we know oh
who's who's the number one science
communicator in the country oh let's
call that guy
right but he's like don't call me call
an expert
and here's another problem neil most
scientists including
scientists aren't very good about
communicating to the public the stuff
that the public needs to know so that
falls on us as scientific community
we've got to do a much better job
we're having trouble with the audio yeah
his hands though we can we can
understand
your microphone connection i think is
loose because we're
picking up a great deal of static coming
out no it's the same
no no no no no
they're better try again
all right i don't think tapping on the
mic is going to make it better
hello does this mean chuck you're giving
neil static
okay so nobody came i can't hear me hear
me no we can hear you you're just very
staticky you're you're breaking up
so really and it's not a connection
because your visual
is perfect oh okay so let me just check
on this here hold on
here yeah that's my connection seems
legit
uh i am now am i okay
no oh man that's still breaking up yeah
okay we can make it out okay chuck
are you gonna have to take you're gonna
have to finish yeah okay so here's the
thing guys just ask me anything
as long as it has nothing to do with
science
and now we will take uh any questions on
jokes about
your anatomy needle i think you're back
on i think we're here
oh you're back there we are okay okay
very nice very good
good to know that give me a few more
questions before we
call it questions there's a lot of
viruses on people's minds so
here's a question from rhonda are there
viruses in space
well we know there are amino acids in
space which are the building blocks of
proteins
and proteins are fundamental to all life
so
uh we don't know we don't know whether
or not there's viruses in space but to
make a virus
uh space is really empty it's really
empty and to make
interesting molecules might you know
peter will attest to this to make
interesting molecules you need a medium
where the atoms can get together and
make an interesting molecule
and if you're in a gas cloud that's
rarefied in spaces
empty and i said this to chuck he
freaked out if the period at the end of
a sentence
if you shrunk the sun down to the size
of the period at the end of a sentence
the next nearest star is four miles away
that's amazing space is empty so space
is not just the right
place to go look for complex molecules
that's all i'm saying
okay well hey here's a good follow-up on
that okay the virus is on people's mind
so which is worse covid19 or
pluto being demoted
where's for whom
but i think pluto's happy now pluto is
like the biggest object in the kuiper
belt of icy bodies in the outer solar
system
whereas before it was the puniest planet
so i think pluto is happy
yeah okay it's no it's no longer it's no
longer uh
masquerading as a planet it can exactly
stealth now
it's it could be it's completely
legitimate in its own skin
right now and pluto didn't harm anyone
so
right right no one died talking about
pluto right
right all right one more one more okay
i'll give you my favorite one and this
is from bangladesh it's from nasrulla
and i hope i'm saying that right in
bangladesh okay this is a good one
if a human colony is established in mars
and a child is born there and raised
there if the child visits earth
would he be considered a human or an
alien
uh it would be an undocumented immigrant
and i'm sorry we got to make planet
earth great again guys
yeah you know the question is not
whether you be
the question is not whether you'd be
human the question is what you'd be a
citizen of what country that's right
yeah right and peter you can test
chemically whether they're actually
human
and they're not some martian in a human
costume
well i was just going to say we'd
probably take her in as a
as a refugee oh canada
well that's a that's that's so
convenient that's a canadian thing
that's so canadian
well we gotta call we to close out this
show this is the first ever virtual star
talk live
um it's been fun to put together and of
course we always we had a little bit of
technical glitches but
i think the content all came through i
want to thank chuck
nice jack such a pleasure always all
good catherine hey ho who did our first
two
segments um peter maffee and i
say that right and of course dave baker
uh and i want to
publicly thank pocket lab for
co-sponsoring
this event so this
has been a production of star talk and
i've been your host neil degrasse tyson
as always
bidding you to keep looking up
good night good day thanks